哎，今天看到一個案例，讓我覺得有點意思。是說那些荷蘭的溫室公司，在中國市場的做法。
怎麼了？荷蘭溫室，我印象中就是技術很強，硬體蓋得很好啊，他們在中國也蓋了很多溫室吧？
對，一開始是這樣沒錯。他們傳統就是把整套溫室硬體出口到中國去。但現在狀況變了，他們開始轉型，不怎麼賣硬體了。
不賣硬體？那賣什麼？是賣裡面的種子，還是配套的肥料啊？這有點出乎意料耶。
他們現在主打的是「軟體」和「系統整合」。簡單來說，就是把那些種植的專業知識，變成一套農業管理軟體來賣。
哇，這點真的很有趣。傳統的硬體製造商，竟然跑去賣軟體服務。這跟我印象中的模式很不一樣。一般人做硬體，頂多就是加值服務或維修保養吧。
沒錯，這點讓我詫異。為什麼一般公司不會這樣做？我覺得可能是因為轉型成本很高，而且軟體服務的開發跟硬體製造是完全不同的領域。
而且他們這樣做的原因是什麼？是中國市場的競爭太激烈了嗎？還是有其他考量？
原文有提到，中國自己的農業技術其實也進步很快，在溫室建設這塊已經追上來了。所以荷蘭公司如果只賣硬體，競爭優勢就沒那麼明顯了。
這樣啊，所以他們等於是把累積多年的「know-how」抽出來，變成一個可以重複販售的「知識商品」。這就不是一次性的買賣，而是可以持續收費的訂閱制了。
我猜這也是他們會這樣做的原因之一。硬體賣一次就沒了，但軟體可以持續更新，提供更多加值服務，建立長期合作關係，這毛利空間可能更大。
對，而且如果客戶用習慣了你的系統，轉換成本也會很高，就像我們平常換手機App一樣，用了很久就不想換了。
不過，這要怎麼具體做到呢？把農業專業知識「軟體化」，感覺就不是件簡單的事。那些數據怎麼蒐集、如何分析、怎麼變成一套好用的系統？
嗯，原文說他們專注在「先進技術、專有軟體和系統整合」這些領域。我覺得重點就是「專有軟體」，代表這是他們獨特的技術優勢，別人短期內還很難模仿。
所以等於是把長久以來累積的種植數據、最佳實踐、專家經驗，全部變成一套演算法，然後包裝成軟體。這確實是個不錯的策略，把無形資產變成有形的商品。
如果我是個小農場主，我可能就會考慮這樣的軟體。如果它能幫我提高產量、節省成本，那我付訂閱費是划算的。
這模式聽起來很棒，但有沒有可能，中國公司過幾年也能自己開發出類似的軟體？這模式能撐多久？
原文寫說，荷蘭公司在這些領域「仍然保有優勢」。表示短期內他們的技術門檻還是比較高的。這就像是，你雖然能自己蓋房子，但裡面的智能家居系統，可能還是要買專業的。
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體說他們「仍保有優勢」。所以說對於台灣廣大的傳統產業或製造業主，這是一個很好的啟發。
確實。我們很多人可能手上都有一些很棒的技術，或是在某個領域累積了很深的專業，但只想到賣產品。這時候或許可以停下來想想，我們的「知識」本身，是不是也有價值？能不能把它變成服務或軟體來賣？
對啊，就像一間開了三十年的麵店，他的獨家配方，與其永遠藏起來，不如考慮看看怎麼把它變成一個可以「授權」出去的服務。不只是賣麵，也可以賣技術。
嗯，或者一個資深會計師，他整理了一套非常高效的報稅流程和模板，如果能把這些流程變成一套小軟體或線上課程，就能服務更多人了。
甚至是一般的上班族，在工作上累積了某種特殊的解決問題能力，是不是也能把這些經驗整理成一套方法論或工具，分享出去？
對，這就好像是把「經驗」和「知識」變現。不論是公司還是個人，好像也提醒了我們，有時候最有價值的，反而是那些看不見的專業。